given one of Doom's great successes is
how well it's brought the nostalgia of
fast-paced rampant brutality of the
classic game to the modern day it makes
sense that it's software has also gone
to great efforts to include a hell of a
lot of callbacks or references easter
eggs and secrets there are already
dozens and more being discovered every
day but here are seven you can watch out
for to start with early on in the first
area of the game you can find our good
friend Dovahkiin from Skyrim this is a
Bethesda published game after all if the
iconic horned helmet didn't immediately
give him away the arrow in the knee of
this long past hero should get your eyes
rolling if it doesn't here's that
reference for the four hundred millionth
time I used to be an adventurer like you
then I took an arrow in the knee if
you've opted for one of the higher
difficulties in Doom you're probably
going to die a lot but if you gotta die
this is the best way to do it in
reference to Terminator 2 at launching
yourself into the lava pit of the
foundry which I have done so elegantly
in this game play clip will cause you to
meet your demise in a fashion perfectly
fitting the Terminator that is with a
thumbs up as you descend into the molten
liquid and your skin presumably fizzles
off your bones if you're a fan of candy
crush or perhaps even the jeweled the
game that candy crush borrowed from you
may want to head to Olivia Pierce's
office in Lazarus labs and have a play
of some demonic and destruction you can
play this one for as long as you like if
you're keen on matching doomed theme
symbols while listening to the original
version of the doom theme in the
background if that last one got your
minigame cravings going you can also
check out the super turkey turbo punch a
three-game elsewhere in the labs this is
much the same Turkey beating destruction
delights that you could find in tomb
three if you find it you can beat the
[ __ ] out of some turkeys there's really
nothing else to it turkeys are really
only good for eating and hitting so
enjoy doing the latter if it's more
gaming references you're after you'll be
happy to hear that commander keen makes
an appearance here as you did in doomed
to the series that kicked off in
software's prominence in gaming has been
honored via this lovely yellow helmet
that you can find on a skull the fact
that the skull is jammed on a stick my
toe
to the secret boss in Doom to create a
John Romero's head on a stick luckily
the icon of sin which hid the
aforementioned Romero head on a stick
can be found later in the game in the
upper necropolis if you fire a rocket at
the boss in a specific spot yes that
specific spot you'll also get yourself a
collectible and some classic audio for
your trouble unfortunately there doesn't
appear to be a John Romero head inside
this one finally I be massively remiss
not to tell you about the classic doom
levels you can find in the new game now
you can search every level for a lever
which will grant you access to a portion
of a classic level somewhere else on the
current map oh you can be a big cheater
and just check out the many YouTube
tutorials which will help you find them
all the offshoot areas feature
old-school graphics and enemy designs as
an added bonus if you get killed off you
can position the camera to see that your
characters face is now the original
pixel I doom guy inside your helmet
obviously these are just a few easter
eggs they be sure to tell us if you know
of any more and how many you found so
far for all the other gory beautiful do
me things check out the rest of our
features on gamespot
you